Transcriber: Ozge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Ahmet Gürsu
Arkadaşlar bu gördüğünüz fotoğrafta
ben 4 ya da 5 yaşlarındayım.
Çok mutlu bir çocukluk geçirdim.
Dedem hâlâ hayattaydı.
Bu fotoğrafta dedemin bana Hac’dan
getirdiği arabayla poz vermişim.
Tabii o zamanlar kurmalı bir arabaya
sahip olmak çok havalı bir şey.
Galiba o yüzden böyle bayramlıklarımı
falan giyip onunla
kameranın karşısına geçmişim.
Tabii daha sonradan öğrendim.
Aslında Da Vinci bu arabayı tasarlarken
sadece bir araba tasarlamak istememiş
Aslında Da Vinci'nin
en büyük hayali uçmaktı
Fakat helikopter gibi havayı
dikey olarak delip yükselebileceğine
inanmadığı için
önce yeteri kadar hızlanması sonra
havalanması gerektiğini düşündü.
Ve bu hem kurmalı sistemi sayesinde
kendi kendine ilerleyebilen,
hem de kullanıcıdan aldığı komutları
devrilmemek için yumuşatarak uygulayan
bu arabayı tasarladı.
Arkadaşlar Da Vinci yani o büyük dahi
en büyük hayalini gerçekleştiremedi.
Uçamadı.
Fakat bu hayaline giden yolda
tarihin ilk otomatik ve
programlanabilir makinesini
icat etti,
yani bu arabayı icat etti.
Ben de küçüklüğümden beri hep böyle
büyük bir adam olmanın hayalini kurardım.
İşte bir taraftan sanat ve bilimin
organik bağına da çok inanırdım.
İşte deneyler yapacağım, bir taraftan
resim çizeceğim, her şeyi yapacağım gibi
düşünürdüm.
Öğrencilik hayatımda da bu hayallerim
hep aslında devam etti.
İşte bugün hatta
birkaç arkadaşım da burada
üniversitede Mühendislik
Fakültesi'nde okurken
arkadaşlarla fotosentezle çalışan
araba yapmaya karar verdik.
İşte dedik ki gittik hocanın yanına
heyecanlı heyecanlı anlatıyoruz
hocam bir fikrimiz var
hidromobili falan bırakalım biz
suyla çalışan
artık su tükeniyor,
biz fotosentezle çalışan araba
yapmamız lazım diye anlatıyoruz.
Hoca dedi ki
çocuklar benim daha iyi bir fikrim var,
osurukla çalışan araba yapın, dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Şimdi gülüyorsunuz ama şimdi
işin daha komik bir tarafı var
aklımıza yattı.
(Gülüşmeler)
Şeyi hatırlıyorum
hani dışarı çıkınca böyle,
lan olabilir mi acaba,
umuda ve azme bakar mısınız?
Neyse sonra mezun olduk.
İşte işe girdik,
çok iyi bir firmada işe girdim,
hayalimde akıllı sistemler
üzerine çalışacağım.
O zamanlar böyle yeni yeni
akıllı sistemler, otomasyon, robotik
falan böyle konuşulmaya başlanıyor.
İnsanlar akıllı evlerden
arabalardan bahsediyorlar.
Ben akıllı şehir yapacağım.
Dünya çapında bir marka olacağız.
İlk gece uyuyamadım.
Sabah iki dirhem bir çekirdek hazırlandım.
İşe gittim.
Dediler ki Orhan müdür bey seni çağırıyor.
5 kat yukarıda zaten
koşa koşa çıktım.
Buyrun dedim.
Orhancığım elektronikçiymişsin, dedi.
Evet müdür bey buyrun, dedim.
Şirkete bir kahve makinası alacağız
ilgileniver, dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Şimdi hayal kırıklığına uğramadım desem
yalan olur
ama kuyruğu da dik tutuyorum,
Allah'tan kahveyi çok severim.
Hani bir taraftan da böyle işin
büyüğü küçüğü olmaz diye giriştim.
Mühendisim ya
analiz yapıyorum
hangisi sütü iyi köpürtüyor ona bakıyorum.
Bir taraftan geliyorum
kim hangi çeşit kahve içiyor?
Kaç kişi kahve içiyor?
Onun analizini yapıyorum.
İşi büyüttüm ertesi gün gittim dedim ki
ya müdür bey bizim kahve makinası
almamıza gerek yok.
Çünkü zaten şirkette bir siz
bir de patron kahve içiyor.
Geri kalanlar herkes çaycı.
Arkadaşlar dedim çaydan şikâyetçi.
Hani alacaksak
önce bir çay makinası alalım.
Orhancığım dedi, daha gençsin.
Bir şey kaçırıyorsun.
Bize burada düşünelim diye değil
söylediklerini yapalım diye
para veriyorlar.
Ben kendimi çok değersiz hissettim
o anda ve o zamandan beri
bu konuya takığım.
Neden acaba benden bir genç olarak
bir şey üretmem bir fikir üretmem değil de
sadece söyleneni yapmam bekleniyor.
Daha sonra yolum Amerika'ya düştü.
New York Üniversitesi'ne yüksek lisans
için gittim.
Hem bu konuyu karşılaştırmalı olarak
analiz etme fırsatı buldum
hem de master tezimi "Gelişmekte olan
ülkelerde teknoloji yönetimi
ve inovasyon algısı" üzerine yaptım.
Bu kapsamda yaptığımız anket
Türkiye'de bu alanda yapılmış
en geniş kapsamlı çalışmalardan biri.
Ve arkadaşlar aslında
şunun sonucunu aradım.
Neden bir şey üretemiyoruz?
Neden icat çıkaramıyoruz?
Neden inovasyon yapamıyoruz?
Ve çalışmanın bana söylediği ilk sonuç
şu arkadaşlar;
çuvaldızı kendimize batırmamız lazım.
Bilmiyoruz.
Örneğin, katılımcılara
geleceği değiştirecek
teknolojiler hakkında
bilgi sahibi olup olmadıklarını sorduk.
İşte nano teknoloji büyük veri falan gibi.
%20 bu teknolojilerden haberdar
olduğunu iddia ediyor.
Bakın özellikle iddia ediyor diyorum.
Çünkü bu teknolojileri sadece
bir cümle ile açıklayın dediğimizde
bu oranlar %5'e düşüyor.
Yani bilmediğimizi de
bilmiyoruz arkadaşlar.
Ya bakın biz bu soruları sokakta geçen
Ayşe Teyze'ye Mehmet Amca'ya sormadık.
Bu ankete katılan herkes
ya temel bilimler
veya mühendislik fakültelerinde
okuyan ya da buralardan mezun
olmuş gençler.
Arkadaşlar beş yıl içerisinde
kuantum bilgisayar dünyayı değiştirecek.
Yani bütün yazılım programlama
dili değişecek.
Ama bizim bu alanda çalışmasını
beklediğimiz gençlerin sadece %4'ü
kuantum bilgisayarın ne demek
olduğunu biliyor.
Hadi geleceği geçtik,
acaba günümüzde günlük hayatta
kullandığımız teknolojilerin çalışma
prensiplerini biliyor muyuz?
Maalesef hayır.
Arkadaşlar ya fotokopi makinasının
nasıl çalıştığını bilmeyen bir insan
3D yazıcıyı hayal edebilir mi?
Geleceği bırakın da yani
günümüzü okuyabilecek
ya da anlayabilecek bilgi ve tecrübeye
beceriye sahip olmadan
nasıl hayal kuracağız?
Nasıl kırk yıl sonrasını
tahayyül edeceğiz.
Özellikle kendimi de katarak söylüyorum.
Yani birinci çoğulda konuşuyorum.
Çünkü ben de mezun olduğumda
hani o kablosuz internette kullanılan
o manyetik dalgalar var ya onların
matematiksel formülünü yazabiliyordum.
Yani onları kâğıda dökebiliyordum.
Nasıl gidiyorlar?
Nerede çarpınca nasıl dönüyorlar?
Ama hesap makinasının nasıl
çalıştığını bilmiyordum,
çünkü bize bu ezberci sistem
aldığımız bilgiyi günlük hayatta
hangi problemimizi çözer,
hiç o öğretilmedi.
Ya felsefe bilmiyoruz biz.
Ne işe yarar günlük hayatta
bunu düşünme fırsatı verilmedi
ve bu ezberci sistem
aynı zamanda arkadaşlar
disiplinler arası düşünme kabiliyetimizi
elimizden aldı.
Ve tarihe baktığımda
ben şunu görüyorum.
Bütün büyük icatların arkasında
disiplinler arası
düşünme kabiliyeti yatıyor.
James Watt,
birinci sanayi devrimini başlatan,
buharlı motoru icat eden
ya da geliştiren James Watt.
Adam boşu boşuna
buharlı motoru icat etmedi arkadaşlar.
Çok iyi matematik biliyordu.
Çark sistemine çok hakimdi
ve müzisyendi.
Üflemeli çalgı tasarlayıp üretiyordu.
Yani muhtemelen havanın nasıl
hareket ettiğini o dönem yaşayan
herkesten daha iyi biliyordu.
Ya da akım fikrini ortaya atan Galvani,
adam hem çok iyi bir fizikçi,
hem çok iyi bir biyologdu.
Eğer bu iki disiplini
bir araya getiremeseydi,
kurbağanın bacağına batırdığı neşterin
neden kasılmaya yol açtığı
sorusunu sormayacaktı.
Ve akım fikrini ortaya atamayacaktı.
Zaten bugün bana soruyorlar
bir toplantıya gidiyorum,
uzmanlık alanın ne?
Valla bende uzmanlık yok diyorum.
Çünkü teknik olarak bugün
bilgi o kadar hızlı çoğalıyor ki
herhangi bir konuda
uzman olma şansınız yok.
Boşuna şunun uzmanıyım,
bunun uzmanıyım demeye gerek yok.
Örneğin tıp doktorusunuz.
Sadece kendi literatürünüzdeki
gelişmeleri takip edebilmeniz için
yılda 125 bin sayfa okumanız gerekiyor.
Günde 342 sayfa eder.
Yani işinizi gücünüzü bıraksanız
sadece okusanız dahi
bir makine kadar uzman olamıyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar bakın insanoğlu artık
birbiriyle yarışmıyor.
Artık makinelerle yarışıyoruz.
Ve ancak ne yaparsak yapalım
bir makine kadar uzman olamıyoruz.
Değer üretmek istiyorsak eğer,
işin içine sanat, tasarım,
yaratıcılık katmak zorundayız.
Ancak bu şekilde katma değer üretebiliriz.
Marka yaratabiliriz.
Ve ben maalesef böyle bir ortamda
lisede, üniversiteye hazırlandığım dönemde
dershaneye gidiyoruz,
dershanede sanat kulübü kurduğum için
dershaneden atıldım.
Müdür babamı çağırmış
yazık demiş ki "hem arkadaşlarına
kötü örnek oluyor,
hem de bundan bir şey olmaz.
Ya topçu olur ya popçu olur.
Alın bunu eve götürün."
Babacığım yazık beni yalvar yakar
dershaneye tekrar yazdırdı.
Ve aynı zamanda dershanede
roman okumak yasaktı.
Ya böyle bir şey olabilir mi?
Halbuki ben bugün Çehov okuyan
bir doktorun benim acılarımı
daha iyi anlayabileceğini düşünüyorum.
Ya da Suç ve Ceza okumuş bir hakimin
ben vicdanına daha çok güveniyorum.
Kafka'nın Gregor Samsa'nı
o işyerinde değersiz hissettirildiği için
bir böcek olarak uyanan
Gregor Samsa'yı tanıyan bir yöneticinin
kendini çalışanlara kötü
hissettirebileceğini düşünmüyorum.
Fakat arkadaşlar geldiğimiz nokta şu;
Türkiye'de %86'nın hiç hobisi olmamış.
%85 boş vakitlerinde sadece
televizyon izliyor.
Ya bu kadar acı bir şey olabilir mi?
Bizim matematik bilen sporculara,
resim yapan mühendislere,
saz çalan öğrencilere,
kendini ifade edebilen gençlere
ihtiyacımız var.
Ama biz bir taraftan hem gençler
burada da dinliyorum,
gençler kendini ifade etsin,
yenilik yapsın diyoruz.
Bir taraftan da onları
hizaya sokmaya çalışıyoruz.
Yani azıcık böyle bir farklı
bir şey yapmaya çalışan
yeni bir şey denemek isteyeni
hemen vurdumduymazlıkla
işte şımarıklıkla ya da ne bileyim
yozlaşmışlıkla suçluyoruz.
Yozlaşmışlık dedim,
hemen bir parantez açmak istiyorum.
Aristoteles MÖ 350'li yıllarda
gençlerin yozlaşmışlığından
dert yanıyordu arkadaşlar.
Yani yozlaşmak diye bir şey yok.
Değişim var.
Ve bu değişime ayak uydurmak zorundayız.
Başka şansımız yok.
Ben 30 yaşıma geldim.
Artık gençliğimin son demlerini yaşıyorum,
uzatmaları oynuyorum.
Bu platform da dâhil
birçok yerde gençlere ilham veren
konuşmalar dinliyoruz.
İşte her şeyi yapabilirsiniz.
Başarısızlık diye bir şey mümkün değildir.
İnanın.
Engelleri yıkın.
Hepsine katılıyorum.
Hepsi çok güzel konuşmalardı.
Fakat arkadaşlar bir taraftan gençlere
sürekli ne yapacağını söylüyoruz da
acaba bu sistemi kuranların,
yöneticilerin,
ikitidar ve güç sahiplerinin
bu işte hiç payı yok mu?
Bu insanların hiçbir sorumluluğu yok mu?
(Alkış)
Yani bir dönüşüm olacaksa
Türkiye değişecekse ve bu değişime
hızlı ayak uydurmak zorundaysak eğer
önce onlar sorumluluklarını
bilmek zorunda.
Yoksa şimdi ben burada çıkıp bir işçiye
patronuna kafa tut, itiraz et diyebilirim,
çok kolay.
Arkadaşlar öğrenciyken hocaya gidip
sınav kâğıdımızı görmek istediğimiz
zaman derste kalmakla
tehdit edildik biz.
Yani böyle bir ortamda
itiraz edebilir miyiz?
Bakın arkadaşlar
gençlere sorduk.
Özellikle Türkiye'de çalışsan 35 yaş altı
hem öğrenim gören, hem çalışan gençlere
dedik ki kurumunuz,
öğrenim gördüğünüz kurumunuz
ya da çalıştığınız şirket
fikirlerinize değer veriyor mu?
%70 hayır diyor.
Kendisini değersiz hisseden bir insan
yaptığı işe, o kuruma, şirkete
değer katabilir mi?
Ve sonuç olarak bugün
aklına yeni bir fikir geldiğinde
bunu yöneticiyle paylaşanların oranı %18.
Bu fikri risk alıp deneyen %8.
Ya arkadaşlar yani biz o katma değeri
yüksek ekonomi var ya
hayal gücüne dayalı
ona elimizdeki ham maddenin,
hayal gücünün %8'ini kullanarak
katılmaya çalışıyoruz.
Aranızda yönetici olan var mi?
Böyle müdür, başkan, amir, duydum.
Şunu söylemeye çalışıyorum.
Sayın amirim,
sayın müdürüm,
sayın başkanım,
değişmek zorundasınız.
Çünkü bakın bu gençleri durduran
en önemli etken sizlerin bakış açısı.
Küsmek yok.
Onları ikna etmek zorundasınız.
Ayrıca bunu onlara insaf edin
onları dinleyin diye söylemiyorum.
Yani siz hâlâ yeni dijital dünyadan
daha fazla kâr etmeyi,
daha güçlü olmayı falan bekliyorsunuz
ama gençler diyor ki
ben bunu ancak ve ancak
daha fazla bilgi
ve daha fazla özgürlükle yapabilirim.
Yani eğer gelecekte Türkiye'yi
ilk 10 ekonomi içerisine
sokmak istiyorsak,
yani biraz patron diliyle konuşayım.
Daha zengin olmak istiyorsanız yani,
daha fazla kâr etmek istiyorsanız eğer
bu gençleri anlamak zorundasınız.
Elinizdeki gücü
maddi manevi gücü
hiyerarşiyi korumak için
ya da onları baskı altında
tutmak için sadece
istediklerinizi yaptırmak için değil,
onlara özgür bir ortam sunmak için
kullanmak zorundasınız.
Bakın arkadaşlar bugün teknik alanda
Türkiye'de çalışanların sadece
%26'si internete engelsiz
erişebiliyor ofislerinde.
Benim bu konuşmamı
arkadaşlarımdan 4 arkadaşımdan sadece
1 tanesi işyerinde dinleyebilecek.
Yahu dünyanın ikinci büyük arama motoruna
Youtube'a giremeyen bir mühendisten
siz nasıl dünyayı tanımasını beklersiniz.
Yani nasıl bu adamın yenilik
üretmesini beklersiniz.
Önce bunu değiştirmek zorundasınız.
Ve gençlere kendilerini değerli
hissettirmek zorundasınız.
Ha biz ne yapacağız?
Oturup ağlayacak hâlimiz yok
ki benim ağladığım da çok oldu.
Böyle durumlarda
hiç bir işe de yaramadığını gördüm.
Arkadaşlar inadına özgürlük talep etmekten
inadına öğrenmekten
ve inadına üretmekten başka çaremiz yok.
Bu isimleri tanıyan var mı aranızda?
Lorenzo, Medici Bandelli, 10. Leo.
Bir kişi bile çıkmadı herhâlde.
Bir kişi var tamam.
Arkadaşlar bu isimler sırasıyla
Leonardo Da Vinci'yi yaşam tarzı
topluma aykırı olduğu gerekçesiyle
ülkeden sınır dışı etmek
isteyen hükümdarının,
onu eli yavaş olduğu bahanesiyle
işten çıkarmak isteyen patronunun
ve kadavralar üzerinde
çalışmalar yapmasını
yasaklayan dönemin papasının isimleri.
Hepsi yaşadığı dönemlerde
Leonardo'dan katbekat daha güçlüydü.
Bir cümlesiyle onun
kellesini alabilirlerdi
ama hiçbirini tanımıyoruz.
Çünkü arkadaşlar
bize bunu da yanlış öğrettiler.
Sahip olduğumuz, güçlü olduğumuz,
tükettiğimiz kadar değil,
ancak ürettiğimiz kadar yaşarız.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)